a fast-moving wildfire in the mountains
near the City of Kelowna British
Columbia on Friday officials there
declared a state of emergency as the
fire destroyed homes and businesses
the McDougall Creek Wildfire is just one
of more than a thousand fires burning
across Canada
up north in Yellowknife residents were
heeding the government's order to
evacuate by noon on Friday a massive
fire is approaching the city from the
East nobody envisioned an event of this
scale
stressful
there's a living room freaking out
officials say the evacuation is
necessary we're heading into a critical
couple of days in this during the
management of this wildfire
we expect to see Northwest winds to
North to West Northwest winds over the
next two days
uh and that those are wins that will
Trend both of those fires in directions
that we don't want while forest fires
are a natural phenomenon U.N officials
say global warming is why Canadians are
living in crisis mode this year we've
seen very very high temperatures this
week including a temperature of 42.2
degrees Celsius in the town of Lytton
which was a new August temperature
record you don't normally and you
shouldn't normally associate 42.2
degrees Celsius with Canada but this is
what we are seeing the forecast for
western Canada widespread and light rain
over the next few days not nearly enough
to extinguish these residents nightmare
Rosalind Jordan Al Jazeera